hey everyone welcome to simulation I'm
your host Don sock in today we're seeing
down through Rodney look gosh how them
rolled Nate all right yes so Alan how
are you good to be here
yes it's such a pleasure to have you all
the way from Italy thank you it's
amazing he's just been teaching at
Berkeley the PhD students yes I've been
helping helping them out yeah yeah got a
great bunch out there yeah a great
department really really good to bomb
yes and they're lucky to have you there
that the professor was was kind enough
to invite me and so I gave a couple of
talks and spoke about my work helped the
students with issues of methodology and
medieval literature and Latin literature
yeah yeah land literature medieval
literature a professor of theology yeah
and the Cora University yes
and so you live in Spoleto pollito
pollito pollito yeah yeah yeah yes
Polito is just north of Rome's about an
hour an hour and a half on the train
from Rome and in the quarry is a hilltop
town in the middle obviously run the
center of Sicily Wow yeah
and so I commute between the between the
two do you think boat I take the plane
Sicily is an island you're right but no
I fly into Catania and and the rest is
easy
cool it's all easy it's all good yeah
very good yeah Sicily is beautiful as
well yeah and not Sicily is has got some
magnificent places you will have heard
of taormina see that was a while a more
cheerful oh wow the egregious the will
say it makes me want to be there huh no
it's I'm a sophomore getting to know it
I didn't really know it I used to go
down to Punta letty an island just south
of Sicily for years and years and years
and it really made it to mainland
systole until I got the position there
about three years ago and it's been a
real eye-opener
one because of the natural beauty of the
place they're artists magnificent places
there yes yes the beaches obviously
great swimming yes great food great
sweets I'm not a sweet tooth at all but
when you when they offer you creme LP
stack you're a sadist which is pistachio
nuts nuts around okay
in a canola which is a typical American
normal is okay when they when they put
the cream EDP stack you were it's
amazing yeah yeah yeah yeah and the
entrepreneurial what can I say seen well
seen the vision I think also of the
people who founded my university it's a
new University cool yeah it's one of the
early universities in Italy that is
expanding rather than contracting
they're hiring the student population is
growing cool yeah
and so this is a university that has an
entrepreneurial focus yes definitely
good that's very I'm here yeah yeah I'm
a type of ambassador if you like it good
yeah
and so maybe some people from Berkeley
will say oh look and not correct well
yes
I actually hope actually recently we've
discovered a collection of rare books
old books early printed books in a
Franciscan settlement just outside in
that which nah I'm not my wildest dreams
I'd love it to turn into something like
Umberto eCos name of the rose
yeah and finds that's the long-lost
discovering books yesterday yes that's
so amazing you learn yes not only
discovering books this is an entire
collection of books that I've had the
luck to discover and sometimes they're
books that just have some subjective
history which can still be some value
you know sometimes it's it's something
that validates something else that's
been written in history and that's
really also
also yeah there are I mean the the
collection has thousands of books there
are manuscripts in Kanab EULA and early
printed books I'm of course interested
in in the first through these first
three categories
but to find a collection like this the
Vatican Library is interested the secret
archives of the Vatican are interested
and as are the as is the department of
attained his studies at Berkeley and I'm
going to invite a few of the doctoral
students down to give me a hand to
catalogue some of these books now of
course my hope is that there is one book
some books that do not exist in other
libraries there is books that will be
literally new discoveries long lost
books etc all rare editions of books
that we know about
well so this hilltop University and of
course sounds beautiful I really want to
go it is actually even now they're three
years teaching philology yep teach us
about what philology is and how you've
been teaching it to the okay great
question thank you
philology is the study of the word
really study of how thought is
transmitted in Italy it has to do with
in my particular field with the
transmission of that thought generally
through manuscript form and so I study
manuscripts or in early printed book
form so the communication of the word or
communication in general the
disseminations
over time of thought but then it's akin
to literature it's yeah yeah it's right
there with literature exam right and
then but then there's a specific study
because then philology could also refer
to something like articles or videos or
music and things like that today yes
today yeah but so in it and so you're
studying it's teaching about it in
manuscript form and in literature form
that's right okay that's what I deal
exclusively with literary texts okay and
so you know Dante patriarchy or more
recently early 16th century authors my
latest book is on baldessari Castillo
and in to meet you Falcone now so that's
so fast so I'm very recent an author
author of the two Renaissance friends
yes and the two Renaissance friends are
Baldus baldassare castiglione
yes and Domus yo Falcone yes and so
we'll let's let's where does that maybe
we should talk about that after some of
the Dante and as you wish let's let's do
that let's go ahead order so yes so
they're professing or teaching you're
teaching other friends and so the
students are learning about the
literature
yeah and how words been communicated
right and so what are kind of the main
important takeaways from that well
in court is a new University and
therefore I have to still have to teach
various things and yeah
so in literature Italian literature
fundamentally and linguistics so I'm
teaching a course in the history of the
Italian language core which is cool
actually
yeah I start from classical Latin I go
right through the Middle Ages
I look at the transformation of Latin
the way in which it becomes Italian have
become this Romance language and a look
at the various authors the various key
moments in history
right until today actually yeah so from
let's say Cicero Julius Caesar Livie
Virgil for example right through to the
newspaper you picked up this morning in
room yeah basically yeah that's so cool
so it's it's a long so long journey but
it's it's sexy it's sexy understanding
language over time is it very sexy
yeah I love it yes there's this whole
thing about George Zipp and he's a
Harvard linguist
and zips law they're not fascinating it
is that the the Pareto principle or
Pareto distributions apply to language
all right how 80% of everything we say
is only 20% of words of all words
so the of and which these villas yeah
yeah along the way hmm
so that applies to Italian as well which
is you know it applies to every language
which is so interesting and then how
does the language actually morph over
time when things like the Renaissance
happen and there's more science of space
and science of what's microscopic and
then how does it evolve when there's a
new period of enlightenment of some new
sort and that's also interesting across
languages across the world and so you've
had the pleasure of learning about it in
the lens of a Italian it's it's become
my passion yeah it really has you know
when you find your your little niche
well I found that years ago now and life
is exciting and that's not false
rhetoric that it really is yeah I think
yeah when you do find something new or
as in this this Dmitry Falcone is a new
entry no one had heard about Dmitry
Falcone who until I discovered him three
years ago Wow in the Vatican Library Oh
interesting nobody was really talking
about who were teaching about him at all
no Wow no no and so because nobody had
went through the Vatican Library in
enough depth to or with that meticulous
and to try and find something new the
Vatican Library contains thousands and
thousands of
Oh scripts not to mention a printed
books and and so even with all the staff
and the funding that it has it's put a
lot of it's put literally hundreds of
manuscripts online in a digitalized form
which is very expensive to do by the way
and yet safely although yes yes yes yes
yes you feel illogically perfect but but
still there is the collection there is
so huge and that's the Vatican Library
yeah and yet there are other there are
archives around Italy I presume the rest
of Europe perhaps even here in the
states we're in a small out-of-the-way
country archives family archives that
have been lying there under dust for 200
years 300 years in our case five six
seven eight hundred years and if you're
not allergic to dust it's a wonderful
spell yeah yeah you learn so much by
being able to go back and look through
that so okay so what is some of these
what is what does the course look like
for the kids that you've put together
there's one for linguistics and there's
one for philology so right is that how
many different courses and what are
those courses look like for the for the
kids well it depends on their this their
studies basically there was a study
course in in arts which only started
this year at the quarry and that is
geared at a certain level there is
another course which is similar always
in linguistics always about the history
of language but it's geared for those
students who will become tomorrow's
primary school teachers oh and so there
are there there are there are different
aims involved obviously and they have to
learn pedagogy
how did yes oh yes yes yes and we have a
a whole army of of colleagues who teach
that I don't yeah different yes and so
the peaches is qualitatively and
quantitatively different but for those
students for these students of what we
call Lake today of Arts no it's it's a
complex indeed it's rather involved and
it does look at language in its
transformation right from pre classical
texts through to to today it is complex
and then what are some of them may be
the highlights that the students learn
in the course with the arts um what what
is something that you know the students
afterward tell you is like whoa or wow
that they've learned about there are if
I may this is a wonderful question yet
and a bit embarrassing because I mean
I'm teaching them this stuff and so I'm
sort of guiding them there are several
wow moments what one particularly is sin
francis of assisi yeah we're in a city
called San Francisco and you know
anaerobes and Francis of Assisi that's
that's important we can come back to
that in a second yes
another one is Dante himself for now
Dante and our Dante it might come as a
surprise so that patanti wrote in both
Latin and vernacular and early Italian
mm-hmm
and it's through a Latin text that we
have the emergence of the very first
linguist in the Western tradition that
has done to himself and how is it
defined that he's the first linguist oh
it's the first person to so he's a poet
for estar it's a first poet the first
intellectual to to pay attention to the
issue of language and how language
changes and is the first one to actually
categorize languages in the Western
tradition that's an important step back
to take yes you can say your fillers
philosophically as well not only
linguistically yes scientifically that's
kind of where philology was birthed kind
of when you take that extra step back
and you look down on the language
exactly any science there any this kind
of works that way right yeah and there
is a metaphor he comes up with and the
metaphor is of this black panther and so
that the dante's panthers aware and of
course the jerk is the pink panther dunt
his pink fans that but it's actually
rather serious the Black Panther leaves
a trail of leaves his sweet fragrance
behind and Dante in the metaphor in this
hunting metaphor goes off hunting for
this black panther around around the
towns of central and northern Italy and
can't find it can never track it down it
can smell its fragrance everywhere but
can't quite pin it down and of course
the Black Panther is a symbol of this
illustrious vernacular that is the
Italian as it should be it should have
been it might possibly have been in a
court system that was worthy of the name
and he goes to Bologna I can't he can
smell it can't really fight it goes down
to room no it's horrible it's all it's
it's a it smells really really bad in
Rome even in Florence and in Luke
pistoia in these towns of of Tuscany
does Dante find it difficult to pin down
this panther even thee as we might call
them dialects but the vernaculars of the
time don't really
come up to scratch really they're not
really on on on a par with this idea of
the illustrious vernacular and so we
have an idea of centers still west
really yes and the illustrious
vernacular this vulgarity loose stray is
what done to himself would try to forge
to create in his work called the comedy
the which we call the divine comedy as
book capture called it a generation
later after Dante we've seen Francis
tears you see we have Dante yes well
then we have the whole issue of language
as a camp as it comes out the early 16th
century and go back to the era of my
book my latest book about Castiglioni so
we have three schools of thought as it
were
we have you might have heard of niccolo
machiavelli the prince
okay in some Machiavellian custody are
in one group and we have a chap called
Equis Cola in another group practically
on his own now and we have Pietro bambo
if you're not an Italian as the mo will
be unknown to most people incredibly
important for us who actually wins he
actually wins this contest as it were
there's this whole debate on language
okay we definitely need a bookmark that
and okay okay see how he actually won
that is that written in your book that's
part of okay that's another topic on
that's on its own okay um okay let's
start with st. Francis de sec okay okay
so yeah teach us about that that's what
year is that okay Sir Francis dies in
1226 okay and the night between the
third and the fourth of October 12 26
and
he dies in or just outside actually a
small church that he had rebuilt called
La Porta Nuova for some Clemens small
portions of the tiny Church and you have
a replica of it here in San Francisco
actually
North Beach is a quality it was built
five six years ago eight years ago don't
know how many recently he writes he
writes a poem which is effectively the
very first poem in Italian literature
I'm certainly literature begins as a
first okay Winston francis of assisi
and it's called the canticles god's got
various names one of which is the
canticle of the creatures and what it is
fundamentally is a cantar sink right or
yes yes and it was actually put to music
it has been put to music
he may have sung it himself but it's
poetry the song of the creatures yes yes
okay yes yes and it is basically an
exaltation a bearing of thanks to to the
Lord for having created creation Oh
before okay answer yeah praise be you my
lord for having created the stars moon
the Sun but also things such as water
such as fire death yeah I thank you for
having created sister death yeah yeah
and this is earlier for it is beautiful
yeah so it was like a it was it was a
token of gratitude for life for
existence yes that's beautiful
okay when he himself is soon to die he
is at the convent of that he had rebuilt
himself could send Damien's just outside
a cz
and where he had housed the the woman
who espoused the perimeter the feminine
principle within the Franciscan movement
that is Sinclair not Sinclair is another
huge chapter nothing to do with Italian
language directly because she only wrote
in Latin a woman writing in Latin on a
par with many other men of the church
who are writing in that and by the way
and therein lies a an issue of what can
I say the the omission of knowledge in
the history of ideas we have a woman who
has been effectively squashed her voice
is not only now beginning to be heard
only now have people started studying
her again but where she is housed he
writes this canticle of praise of thanks
and therefore ashes in Italian
literature after the great season of
Provence our literature we have the
birth of this great European literature
in a vernacular which is not Tuscan it
is Umbreon Umbreon the region next to
Tuscany just north of Rome and it is a a
node it is a canticle of thanks there's
so that's so interesting
I do we know of anyone ever in the past
writing a canticle of thanks before st.
Francis the Bible's full of canticle of
canticles of that correct one of the
main sources for the canticle of the
creatures is of course the song of songs
okay it's also the the Beatitudes
blessed are the meek for they it's such
a blessed that other poor blessed Osetra
house in
and so Jesus on the Mount actually
teaching people to be thankful and using
this anaphora chol structure in in his
poetic sermon which becomes across the
basis for for Francis it's important
also from a programmatic point of view
and therefore political because Francis
I'm not going to get through this T
actually because you can see that the
passion yell Francis could easily have
been termed a heretic heresy had a
definition in the Middle Ages one of the
facets one of the hallmarks of heresy
what was to go about preaching in the
vernacular translating the Bible into a
vernacular that is making it available
for people who could not read Latin to
read
doing so out there on the street of life
with women the very fact that women
might have been in your fold was enough
to have you and your whole movement in
his case a penitential movement labeled
as heretical and so he he keenly knew
that there's also a division America we
call it a manic a and division that is
where you have a tale of two cities
Paris and London as in Dickens or you
have at the black and the white or the
day and night the Sun and the moon
one is that one is necessarily positive
the male principle is positive in the
Middle Ages the female principle is
necessarily negative hmm now if you
espouse if you take on this realistic
understanding of the cosmos it means
that there's a whole section of creation
that you are denying
right when Francis who was accused time
and time again of being quasi heretical
he writes the canticle of the creatures
because the cantaloupe reaches and
everything comes together yeah
everything creature is not in the sense
of the sense that we give it today
northern time a mouse or Bambi it's
everything everything that has been
created by God so everything is this
exists has been co-created and therefore
everything effectively is our brother or
sister sir yeah correct
yeah and for which Francis thanks yeah
father that's amazing okay so that's st.
Francis right that's 12 20 is that's
really great that's a good stepping
stone for so many to understand the
thanks for existence okay next up Dante
is right around like a little laughter
that's right a little after him he's
putting 12 1265 and then his main things
to divine comedy right and Dante was an
exiled yes why did he get exiled he was
in the wrong political party okay so
it's kind of like what happens today
when you speak out against a dictator in
a country that rules okay well here we
do not have one dictator there is a
leader of the opposing faction
his name is Corsa Donati the Donati
family an important Florentine family
Dante's own wife belonged to the Donati
family right away Wow and they're called
black quilts Wow he spoke out against
his wife's family oh well he was
actually exiled through no direct fault
of his own he was actually away at the
time he was on a diplomatic mission at
room at the Holy See either going to or
coming back from we don't know and he
found out that he had been exiled what
does being exiled mean in the Middle
Ages well when you have the concept of
the city-state there was analogy we
could actually draw with with ancient
Greece actually of the other Poly's so
everything revolves around the city's
state and its immediate territory you
know that the gates of any medieval city
are opened at 6:00 in the morning
they're closed at 6:00 at night if
you're in great if you're not you never
will be that night okay there are
exceptions you to be exiled that's so
interesting I just I just can't I just
imagined what that's that's like it's
the gates open so you're trying to be up
as early as possible to be able to leave
go do whatever you need ready done
engage interactive level and once the
Sun is setting you need to get your butt
back into town straight away straight
away strip them and then the gates
closed and then there is people
observing and washing to make sure from
the top to make sure that there's no
bandits or people that are trying to
harm to people inside all these draw
more exactly a whole whole numbers of
that itself is just so fascinating that
that used to exist than that I just
sometimes I get you know sometimes I
almost you know I basically tear up I do
like thinking about history in that
sense because it almost part of me
almost goes back to my soul potentially
being alive at those times or what do
you mean by that
having lived through it through other
people so through your reading you mean
well kind of but also in a very
spiritual way I don't know how to
explain it get to the point down why
don't you explain it well you're making
reference to reincarnation of sorts and
which and so part so Sauron gives you
part of it part of it is reincarnation
but the other part of it is the global
consciousness the collective
consciousness as an yet well tapping
well tapping into what those humans were
experiencing 800 years ago hmm
tap just being able to tap into that
experience and being alive through every
one of their eyeballs through their
excuse me that that's some feat you're
just describing not to be able to tap
into those lives that we lived out and
to look at the world through those
eyeballs yeah I'm now 54 I've been
studying these same phenomena for 35
years and I can't say that I can do that
I have peeps every so often I'm not
living through it breath right I'm just
I'm trying to get little I'm trying to
maximize the amount of peeps and I'm
trying to and I'm trying to help other
people you can see those peeps because
it gives us a more dimensional
perspective into the nuance of what
civilization went through to get to the
point of where we're at today right
instead of just living in the conceiving
that here and now yeah advertising
dopamine rewards all the time right it's
really good to just you know I I
actually did bear I did actually barely
tear up because it is so [ __ ] it is
just beautiful to get those peeps I like
how you call it a peep and that's what
it is I know it is exactly it's just a
peep
that's why we do this show I get a
little I get a peep from you you get a
peep from me they get a peep from the
conversation right maybe maybe and I
think it's I think it's really important
to get you know we just had yesterday we
were talking about biohacking and the
importance of ketones
and exogenous ketones into your body and
fasting and things like this now and
what you know even though that's such a
future thing is these ketone drinks at
the same time it's a little peep into
your inner mechanisms when you fast your
glucose drops and if you really feel
that feeling then your liver starts
burning fat and that's when you go into
ketosis and so again so you get this
peep you get little peeps like that into
his other realm different realms yeah
yeah philology gives that to me I a lot
of my friends back in Australia and
indeed around the world now they dating
Lee does yes think that I lead that I'm
always partying having you know vino
grapa and pasta and what-have-you sure
but I actually lead a rather quiet
existence in Italy especially my home
outside Spoleto I spend hours and hours
and hours and hours and hours a day and
that means weeks that means years on my
own in my studio which is a small
building outside I have a 14th century
watchtower oh my god on four levels it's
it's wonderful it's called a cherry in a
place called put it and Ron and I are
coming
Vinicio simulation to Italy yeah and
there is no greater satisfaction in my
life and I'm talking about food and
talking about sex I'm doing about
conversation comes close yes yes the
peeps yeah but when you're sitting in
your at your desk and you suddenly
realize what the narrative technique is
what you realize what is really being
communicated through that text which
probably in Latin yeah or in early
Italian and you realize that because you
know the critical literature that you're
the first person to have understood oh
and that's cool and the first there is
there is if I may say so there is no
greater satisfaction correct and that's
a real hit and I can piggyback on that
just a little bit because I gain these
I'm not the first like you are to get
that essence of literature from someone
but what I can say about um the same
greatest feelings in life are when I sit
across from you and you are the one or
the like I was explaining the the team
from yesterday those who eyes yesterday
that are doing what they're doing that
they sit here and they teach me and as
I'm your on a privileged position here I
structure what you're saying and you go
you know st. Francis the the song of the
creatures and when you say that and I go
aha I have the Eureka moment for myself
right and then I go wow that's so cool
minds expand in new dimensions that's
what happened as well okay so we were
talking about 6:00 a.m. to 6:00 p.m. all
right okay and that was a part of Dante
we were well that's that's that's the
ancient world
that's how hmm until you get a certain
development in warfare and that
particularly development of cannon
cannon yes
Canon's certain grams are also well
battering-rams have always been around
around the early 16th century there's a
huge development in in warfare whereby
the army could actually place itself at
a greater distance from a city Wow and
if you have tall walls that are
relatively thin they can be easily
knocked out yes
and so wall city walls have to become
lower but also much thicker thicker and
there's a wonderful city called Luke in
Italy which has these these walls that
are kind of effectively cannon proof
Wow how are they can impervious because
they know I've never measured them
they'd be ten meters thick but then the
promise that cannons will then shoot
over the walls if they're too short
yes yes but it's also been very costly
to to create to build I mean these are
the efforts that take generations
correct exact and I can't imagine that
what expense for for the citizens of
that time to actually yeah have to put
up with and then they live there for
hundreds if not a thousand years in that
place that they actually built over
generations with her but they're I'm
supports when tears when when Dante is
exiled when anyone is exiled they have
to leave for well they have to leave the
thing is they lose all civil rights any
citizen if there is a death sentence
any citizen of that town can actually
kill a an exile that is no
rehabilitation that can be there can be
Dante's properties were by and large
confiscated but his wife and his
children was still allowed to remain
there allowed to remain in inside
Florence a good the family doesn't get
exiled just to relate it can happen yeah
it can happen there were at least two
occasions in which done there was
afforded a pardon and the thing is with
Dante Dante is at the end of the day
exile is a positive factor because had
dant had not been exiled he might have
remained a municipal poet a good letter
writer director and we would not have
had for sure we would not have had this
first treatise on linguistics which song
was called the eloquence of the
vernacular and we would definitely not
have had the comedy yeah and let's let's
unpack that so he goes into exile yeah
where is exile and then what good
question what is excel where is XO exile
is everything outside your city walls
okay and Susanna here talking about
Florence okay about 1302
okay and Florence is at war with at it
so which my car today is an hour's drive
it's at war with Siena it doesn't get on
with historia go to different political
colors there are some secrets that
actually supports the papal cause other
cities that call that support the
imperial cause what are those can you
explain those quickly Church and Empire
okay so we have a macro the macro level
we have these two we have these discs on
tracking these contrasting forces at
loggerheads Church the Pope or in
Dante's time a few years into his exile
the perp act that the paper section
moves from room to a beanie on in what
is now southern France in Provence and
it stays there effectively for most of
the 14th century and is called
the Unitarian the captivity Avignon ETA
and so this captivity even Avignon on
the one hand so we have the Pope's who
are also kings they have they are keen
as they own States they own
they have their armies they actually
invade why and kill in order to take
over other cities yeah on the one hand
on the other we have the Emperor and the
Emperor in there are certain periods in
which there is no Emperor and so the
Empire was out with without a leader and
he at least in name has power over life
and death of every citizen in
Christendom from Jerusalem up to
Scotland with n everything in between
it's crazy now they're a little peep
into what would that person's life the
king or the person that owns or what did
they do to their life journey to get to
that point and then as what goes through
their mind when they're in control of
all these people and resources going and
trying to get more and lots of things we
must talk about certain families that
that vie to with the Empire there is
there are competing elements one of
which is German lore against Roman law
now and they are very often compatible
but not always in Roman law we have
inheritance and inheritance also of a
title well in German law however that's
not necessarily the case that is your
son doesn't necessarily become the
leader of the clan of the village of the
kingdom yeah
in this case of the Empire and there's
the in German mother be potentially a
vote that
yes exactly there are certain people who
are allowed to vote and others who are
and within there in the later Middle
Ages after the Year thousand let's say
in the 1213 hundreds and Dante's time
are there only about seven or eight
grand
electors they're called and these people
can be
Bishop's they're normally Prince's and
they get together and they elect a the
king of the Germans he was always called
first and then he was possibly also
crowned Emperor well he said there's all
these different historical differences
in the way that we we live and we people
in power and what the rules of law are
so Dante's exiled as he's exiled he is
potentially some of the reason why he
writes the Divine Comedy and what why he
describes his heaven hell purgatory is
because of his exile if he wasn't then
we potentially in this the same thing
applies to a lot of our world today is
when we when were put into situations
that we put stress on us in different
ways it's funny how fast we move forward
oh yes definitely and so that's what we
were talking about it you know Tony
Robinson's necessity the mother of
invention that's it necessity the mother
of invention yeah that's great yeah you
know a little fire under your ass and
you get cracking you get moving Frankie
it's right he so teach about the Divine
Comedy and heaven hell purgatory let's
talk about that okay great Don T's in
exile and therefore being in exile being
an exile means that you were
automatically in a different realm and
you have a different mindset you are on
the run you do not have any steady
income someone such as Dante could not
really become a blacksmith Yeah right he
didn't have a trade he could write
letters and so he'd write this is the
people he he knocked on many a court
door saying let me in let me in some
people did that many didn't yeah for
various reasons yeah
[Music]
first of all exile means for Dante
remaining around Florence because he
hopes to be allowed back in and and a
year goes by five years go by ten years
go by and he realized that's not going
to happen a second amnesty was actually
proclaimed at one stage however he would
have had to do penance that he's
covering himself in sackcloth and
charcoal ashes in his hair run around
the baptistry of Florence I don't know
how many times three times I think and
ask for forgiveness
because he happened to belong to the
wrong faction and he says I was
purported to have said this is no way to
invite Donatella gaiety back to Florence
I prefer to remain in exile which he
does now entire generations of scholars
in Italy and outside Italy have asked
the same question that is that why write
the comedy as he did that is with he'll
purgatory and heaven that is what's the
point
yes why create this Jared the idea of
the journey for the three realms of the
afterlife that as a living person in
order to to say what what's the ultimate
aim well there are many answers to that
and no particular answer to that
Oh beta there are certain answers that
are valid for the various realms let's
go with the most well-known answer is
there why is there one yeah a good one I
like because I've been dealing a lot
with the Paradiso with the with the
heaven in the last few years Paradiso
Paradiso and in Paradiso in heaven dant
actually puts people together these are
people who have made it right these are
people who did not were not sent to hell
or you were sent to hell if you were
born before the advent of Christ right
and support Virgil hmm okay the greatest
Latin poet ever who was actually Dante's
the character Dante he's guide right
through hell right through purgatory is
dues to spend eternity in limbo right or
you get into hell you are sent to hell
if you have not been baptized and so
it's it's obviously it's in a Christian
paradigm and and so the the Christian
element you must be a kree a baptized
Christian in order to move up as it were
if you are in hell you will always be in
held
end of story if you gets into purgatory
it means that prima or boy eventually
you'll make it now a way to hurry things
up of course is to have is to leave a
lot of money with the people you've left
behind so that they actually have masses
celebrated for you every morning and
that actually move you up more quickly
interesting right
sometimes even though you may have spent
an entire life fighting against the
church fighting against Christ but on
your deathbed or in the case of certain
princely what can I say
warriors one one tier of contrition will
be enough to actually make you well
allow you to get into purgatory in
heaven if you make it into paradise or
you've made it and what does it what
does it mean to have made it it means
that you actually can spend the rest of
eternity contemplating the face of God
whatever that might mean dan to himself
does just that in the last two cantos of
the parody song but what does Dante do
there was an entire branch of critical
literature regarding his anti Islamic
stance he is Christian in the Middle
Ages it's like being anti-semitic in the
Middle Ages many people it is part of
institutionalized faith as it was man
right here right
my deity is right yes of course okay
fine who is the infidel well the other
guy yeah obviously yeah right and yet
and yet
what does Dante do in peril in heaven in
the Cantor number ten and were a third
of the way practically through his
journey through through heaven he puts
these two enemies together now one is
lead the leader of the Thomas Dominican
Order the other one is a man
who espoused who had taught at Paris the
University of Paris some ideas that were
felt to be by the Dominicans they were
felt to be a heretical and he taught a
an Islamic philosopher called a burr
always could actually taught in Moorish
Spain a couple of centuries beforehand
that you know you can actually arrive at
contemplating God through the
development of your soul intellect so
intellect itself can be enough to
contemplate God that is without faith
huh now obviously her vertical obviously
not Catholic not Christian or not in the
canonized not in the scholastic version
of that at Paris and the leaders the
Dominican leaders at Paris the time
actually have this man killed this man
is called Sid Jerry Bieber abandoned a
and he is assassinated in in in Italy at
the papal court by the way what does Dan
they do he puts them together they are
sitting together for eternity hmm
know what and they where as in life as
you're alive they had been mortal
enemies each the Nemesis of the other so
what is the ultimate aim of the Paradiso
what is the ultimate aim of the comedy
to teach that reconciliation is indeed
possible the reconciliation even between
someone who had born that the star that
at the banner of standard Christian
faith on the one hand the other one the
banner of Islamic thoughts yeah and
though himself a Christian could
actually sit together harmoniously yeah
singing songs of praise awesome
opportunity so how was that
communicated through the Divine Comedy
through the Paradiso how was that
communicate there is okay there are
certain formations that Dante sees and
generally they are angels in Spoleto be
giving this Friday a talk on the ladder
Jacob's Ladder
in in the Paradiso pattern as heaven 21
is Divine Comedy chunked up by Paradiso
purgatory in hell yeah there are these
three sections there are three sections
three sections there are 3-3 canticles
they're called this words coming up very
often love it well it's because yeah
composing poetry and singing go hand in
glove yeah yeah and like you said a
necessity is the mother of invention or
of invention so again it's like these
shorter more concise phrases yeah
exactly
yeah that's the canticle it's a singing
it's a singing to describe existence or
life and showing indeed indeed he does
that too parodies yes that's you okay so
one more time so Paradiso focuses on two
people do they even throw from different
backgrounds or different mindsets can
still ring reconcile and sit
harmoniously absolutely and then what's
the sense of purgatory in the essence of
Hell as well for a start the afterlife
I'll be at least three different realms
is full of noise the noise that we hear
in Inferno in hell is of course
cacophonic we you hear people screaming
you hear Devils cackling there are
people crying this is great exactly and
so there is a there is this cacophony
did all the time in in Vietnam
so it's full of noise and the ultimate
aim basically there are other they were
actually precedents there actually other
forms artworks frescoes depicting fire
depicting punishment after death indeed
we spoke before about this this
dichotomy that is black and white night
and day man woman well they used to be
only Heaven and Hell there is one line
by some Paul who says that your sins
will be purged through fire and from
that one line the whole dogma of
purgatory was developed in the Middle
Ages as this separate realm where people
would actually purge their sins purify
themselves others work their sins away
as it were in order to finally get into
heaven and purgatory is depicted
imagined as this setting so purging
their sins away yes so it's a state
between the heaven and the hell you
you're trying to purge your sins away to
get into paradise yes and that will take
hundreds if not thousands of years
all right and the purgatory is imagined
by Dante to be a mountain and which is
probably in the middle of the Atlantic
Ocean somewhere it's outside the
Mediterranean Basin as ELISA there's a
spot for this why is there a spot for
this because according to the medieval
mindset and how medieval man thought the
world to be when Lucifer the most
beautiful angel was actually thrown down
forced out of heaven and hurled down to
have to the earth plane he fell okay and
with such force that he ended up at the
very center of the earth and therefore
he displaced that amount of Earth sir
through the other side creating this
mountain oh that's cool
which happened to be in the middle of
the Atlantic some and it gave people the
chance then to get to paradise the
mounded yes okay and so paradoxically
paradoxically but you know Lucifer is
actually sitting at the very center very
bottom of a pit so our hell waiting
waiting for the likes of me and you
perhaps if we're unfortunate enough to
be relegated to to hell
so purgatory is a mountain and you
arrive there by boat and there is a
whole tradition that it's probably
Etruscan so pre-roman from Italy you are
put onto this boat going you are taken
down the Tiber because the Tiber as you
may know today it starts in Romania this
other region why because the dictator
Mussolini was romagnolo and he changed
the borders of the regions of Italy so
then the Tiber would actually start in
the region which he had been born okay
okay in Dante's time said before the
20th century the Tiber was also like the
honor the Tiber
was also in Tuscany I want us to get to
everything so let's go more rapid okay
okay because we also have the four clock
as well and we want to get you in the
portrait book so well let's let's go
let's go let's go a little bit more sure
a longer way so okay so we just did
purgatory or trying to finish purgatory
so the idea of purgatory is to purge
your sins yep okay so that you can
actually get into heaven Wow okay yep
and then that's through a lot of
introspective process you got to look
inward through punishment through
punishment through punishment yeah there
are various punishments there are
punishments in hell that are eternal no
way out that's it
so are we on hell now when we can be
the punishments in purgatory just to
finish on that will eventually end you
will eventually when you first get
admitted into purgatory you have seven
P's branded on your forehead and yes
with every end the P a key is peccato
peccato meaning sin so they have the
seven deadly sins oh yeah branded onto
your forehead and I get removed one by
one I think Ron has like 15 deadly sins
honest it's know what yes now what hell
yeah hell is a wonderful place hell is
the the first canticle is the cantle
that most everyone who knows done they
loves hell because it's much more
dramatic the language is gutsy you it is
really it's Hellfire and brimstone it's
yes it's its hellish literally hellish
and yet there is there are several
moments in hell the first one of course
is the most famous canto number five
counter number five we tells a story of
[Music]
star-crossed lovers a brother-in-law has
fallen in love with his sister-in-law
and there is a macho there is a kiss and
whether this kiss should be understood
as neutralism for something much more
it's probably the case but this is
effectively the very first time in well
since Roman times since classical
literature that we have a kiss that we
have that very of sexuality actually
emerging in literature not even that not
even in the province our paradigm did we
have and
a woman kissing that is the embrace the
sexual embrace and this has to do with
hell because we are in hell because it
is a question of incest it is a question
of infidelity okay we have a betrayal
okay and therefore by canon law these
two lovers are to be relegated to hell
for eternity and this is a story in the
Divine Comedy
Dante's writing absolutely now her name
is Francesca his name is Paolo Paolo and
Francesca and Paul in France was Pablo
Francesca well actually it's really odd
because as you said there's a whole
series of firsts from Francis on the
first year is that it's not Paolo
speaking it's not the man speaking on
behalf of the woman what does Paolo do
right what the canto he is sobbing he's
crying he can't cope there is this
infernal wind that has been blowing
around the wind of loss the wind of
passion and Dante actually asks Virgil
if you might be able to go over and
speak to them and they come over to him
like doves and it is as if the wind
stops for a second and she speaks and
she speaks about this love that was born
that was created that came into
existence between her and Paul or where
why how because they have been reading
about the knights of the round table and
where Lancelot and Guinevere had
actually discovered that they too had
fallen in love with each other
and so we have the idea of love
begetting love this mizzen I mean this
is this abyss with love actually drawing
us to love yeah
because we have in dentist and the whole
idea of social movements that is how
does one move up put socially if one is
not noble well you do that by perfecting
your intellect by becoming a poet yeah
right they're becoming an intellectual
and therefore by developing a more
refined more courtly idea of love so the
whole court courtly love paradigm the
more Courtois paradigm is fundamental
here it means that you are already an
elect spirit if you know how to love
courteously mmhmm right yeah yeah but
we'd be gentle with your love be within
this dance as we call it right of law
right right because that's a derivative
of the whole paradigm here okay so is
there something else that we should
mention from the Dante and from exile
literature and Divine Comedy another one
of those Wow things are a million and
one there's so many to do yeah we'll
have to do more of the Wow's okay when
we when we bring simulation to Italy for
some vino and some pasta good
conversation so maybe let's as quick as
possible let's touch on to Renaissance
friends what's a good wow from okay yeah
the book to Renaissance to renaissance
friends is a collection of poetry in the
case of castiglione the first of the two
authors this poetry was already known
even though most of it even though there
are some new pieces that I've discovered
do bicho Falcone is completely new he is
someone who's been overlooked by
scholarly
endeavor scholarly work what's
fascinating about Dimitri Falcone many
things he worked at the court he lived
at the court of Mantua and so we entered
the Gonzaga rule mantra is in
north-central northern Italy northern
Italy it's in lower long body that means
anything to you
just south of Milan I want to get to as
much of the essence right now as we can
and we'll get to the more details as in
our later discussion is just because
we're cutting it close on some time and
I wanted it again some of this essence
what is like them okay yeah yeah okay
here we have the emergence of a treatise
on love again but love and not spiritual
love but love in the here in the now and
he becomes he is acclaimed as by the
Gonzaga's by Castilian a as being an
expert on love that is love at its at
its most base and so in his exultation
of Priapus the ever erect gods of the
lesser the lesser God of the
kitchen-garden in Roman times with his
ever erect penis and from the Ryan has a
penis as true haha on the one hand on
the other side like my dick he wrote
about it and so moving right up to
various types of relationships
heterosexual homosexual but never
talking about spiritual relationships on
the one hand on the other it's also but
history of art if you know the painter
mantain yeah there was a first in this
book one of the firsts it is mean as
much as do mr. Falcone actually writes a
piece an epigram on a painting that we
no longer have
the painting that that Mantinea had
painted on the race between hip homilies
in atlanta you might remember the one by
guido reni in which there is a race it
is it's about alchemy really answer the
transformative nature of love yet again
in art I was so transformative anyway
anyway right
he ponies or Atlanta is a goddess people
manie's is not his mortal but they're
both that she actually races against her
lovers and when if they lose and they
invariably do because she is a goddess
she kills them
he prominence everybody comes up with
the golden apples and Ichi and he throws
these golden apples at and she Stoops to
pick them up so she actually has to slow
down okay and then they fall in love
with each other and we would not have
known that Monte Nia had actually
painted this had it not been for don't
meet your fellow on it okay so all right
this is again we're just so amazingly
exploding mind into history and
understanding how you know philology
actually works with language from this a
really top-down perspective of how it's
being communicated to other people we
get these little peeps into history that
we've been discussing it's been so good
alright let's do a couple simulation
questions for you the first question
let's ask you is how do you think we can
maximize human potential
but conversing more reading more and by
studying philology pathology really is
that dance between your understanding of
the word in the word itself yeah and so
really it's about its mean it's really
self analysis yeah at the end of the day
yeah the Nets of albeit through the
paradigm of history of other texts
written by other people yep with this
interdisciplinary approach that is
history of art with everything images TV
yep and so it's your relationship
between yourself and the outside world
yeah yeah in the understanding that is a
main pillar in trying maximizing you're
seeing a wid that's all that you should
being aware that you should yeah is your
name and then trying to become an expert
at it that's one of the main ways to
become a master of oneself is through
this process yeah right okay so good how
about what do you think's the most
beautiful thing in the world
the most beautiful thing in the world
God looking at the Stars
looking over the valley from my Terrace
with a glass of white wine around six
o'clock huh super knowing that I'm going
to go to do now I have dinner at my
place with lovely friends that's amazing
great answer how about what do you
thinks the purpose of life again these
are the big questions the purpose of
life I don't know the purpose of life in
my case is to not leave any damage to
better myself as a person to not further
knowledge that's not the point here in
my work because my work is my passion is
my life
- I don't want to say to spread joy it
sounds too facile and too infantile it's
good but that's what it boils down to to
be an example first of all for myself
and for those immediately around me of
how you can actually get joy from from
from life
I certainly do do that - I do I do
yeah I know I'm never going to become a
millionaire but who cares really yeah
impact is really the most important
thing not the money it's the impact
that's the most important thing right
yeah I know that I have greater sense of
worth because of what I do yeah it's
important
yep and people tend to like it yeah yeah
a lot of this stuff is really really bad
it's really moving it's really move this
we got moved several times in this
conversation I got moved several times
in this conversation and I feel like by
through my movement you got hopefully
people at home did - okay how about what
is one of your greatest fears but what
is your greatest fear a greatest fear
well I'm not I'm not afraid of dying I'm
not even really of pain fear
do I have fears that people are going to
realize that I'm only full of passion
aren't really I'm not really an expert
and what I am talking about but that
that is that disappeared straight away
as well
I realized they were a certain series of
anxiety sources of anxiety about that
not knowing for example when I went to
Berkeley last week not knowing what I
would find
yeah and but you know and I realized
that I'm fairly lucky if these are my
fears yeah I'm lucky are we alone in the
cosmos
whoa probably not you know I used to I
used to ask myself these these same
questions years ago as little kid I used
to stand outside in the backyard in
Australia saying Martians Martians come
down and fetch me I want out of this but
I realized in my late teens I think that
it doesn't really matter it doesn't
really matter whether reincarnation
exists doesn't matter even whether God
exists or Paradiso exists what really
does matter is the quality of life we
must all strive individually and
collectively to to have here no good and
then do you think we're in a computer
simulation um I hope not but no I don't
think we know it'd be sad it'd be really
really sad if we were why would it be
sad sad think of the the people
manipulating this reality oh yeah and
how vacuous their lives must be
and if anything if that were the case
we're probably living leading the better
existence anyway and I think um to hell
with them all right Ronnie what a
pleasure thank you it's always
pleasurable for me to talk about my work
I love teaching and sharing and this is
unusual for me as a situation but I
thank you I think you sincerely thank
you thank you so much right
Ronnie Lukasz thank you for joining us
we covered so many great topics I would
be your student for a very long time and
we'll come visit you'll come visit good
Spoleto at in ray :
yes yeah Copa de vino with the sunset so
thank you for tuning in we covered so
many great topics that I love the peeps
we're definitely gonna have to keep the
peeps as something that we're gonna have
people who peeps are great um that was
good and then it was necessities the
mother of innovation was another one of
invention of attention I think I might
have translated that from the Italian or
from the Latin I figure I don't know I
don't remember anymore you know that's
where this language is a human go
philology makes sure to look that up
your deeper into understanding that and
if you guys had a good time like comment
subscribe check us out on patreon give
us a little bit of support that would be
very helpful if you found the content
useful definitely share it with others
thank you everyone for tuning in thank
you Ron Vargas our producer director see
ya Malloy
[Music]